foreign
[Music]
hey guys what's going on it's a new day
dude
congratulations podcast uh welcome to
the new episode of congratulations
[Music]
I can't wait for Minneapolis this
weekend I can't wait for Minneapolis on
Saturday Milwaukee Friday the day before
and then I gotta take a month off I'm
taking a month off I think uh until May
when I go to Columbus and Cincinnati
Ohio uh and I just announced dates in
Pueblo Colorado where is it Colorado
Springs Colorado where is it in Tucson
Arizona uh I've been there once
um so go to chrissy.com get tickets I'd
be in Salt Lake be in a bunch of
different places and all that [__]
um the great thing about today is I'm
nauseous as [__] so that's awesome
that's just great that is just fantastic
that I'm so nauseous it's so fantastic
I'm so nauseous and it's so fantastic
that no matter what for two weeks my
tummy is going to be doing all sorts of
things so that's great dude camp can't
even I mean that's just so great so
thank god dude it's like winning the
lotto only you
um have to keep going potty and also you
think maybe you might throw up so that's
great dude I mean I'm so happy about
that
um
and uh I got my new sunglasses they're
red so everybody watch out I'm gonna be
looking a little bit spicy uh and uh I
do have yellow sweats on so I was
walking around today pretty spicy and I
got red sunglasses on and yellow sweats
on walk around pretty spicy so it's all
good and I was thinking about man A lot
of people are like dude you're 42 or
whatever the you know you're 40 what
what are you what are you trying to do
with your the way you dress and it's
like you know yeah and then I actually
was in Austin
uh I did my shows and I'll get to that
they were great but I was leaving Austin
and I ran into James Marsden who's like
the nicest guy in the world you know and
he was like Hey Chris and I was like oh
what's up dude and we shook hands and
then I walk away and I was like how you
been he's like you live in Austin I'm
like nah uh I'm just doing a show here
and maybe he lives in Austin I have no
idea but I walked away and I'm like man
that sound really like there's a like he
looks good he's a handsome dude he's
aged well and like he's just dressed
well
and I'm like I dress like I'm in a
hoodie and like
and then I'm like man I'm 40 something
years old and like
people are like yo why you dress like
that and it's like
maybe I just need to start dressing with
like button downs and a really nice
Blazer you know and just a really nice
blazer with like nice jeans and those
shoes that like
you know
the like kind of they're not their boots
I guess but like you just slip them on
and then they're like
the the kind that like
you you like the town is just gentrified
and then the people are wearing those
boots
and I'm like man you that's the kind of
thing that's the kind of guy that's the
kind of guy I want to be like though
that's what James Marsden is like he's
like the kind of guy you see him and
you're like ah maybe I gotta like
maybe I gotta like buy some sort of like
V like like or like a crew neck from
you know maybe I should go to like J
crew
you see that's the kind of guy I gotta
be like dude
you know
it's like we talk about grower grow or
die that's what I talk about on that's
what I taught on this podcast and it's
like dude
yeah but also I just keep flossing with
these hoodies
I just keep getting real nice with it of
course dude he keeps adding laces to the
shoes because that's what the hype bees
say and ah you know it's not like I've
got an over the shoulder bag but dude I
keep the I keep the sweats cuffed and
then when they said go wide at the end
your boy bought once
that were white at the end
you know they Bunch up real nice over
the laces so it's like
all right
but maybe people see me and they're like
I gotta get more hip I don't know dude
but all I'm saying is you see James
Marsden in the airport and you start to
doubt your ways because that dude's got
a nice smile dude and he looks in your
eyes and it's just like man
I don't know
I'm impressionable what can I say babies
I'm impressionable but aren't we all in
a bit uh maybe we're not all maybe we're
not all impressionable but my gosh dude
was I not at if I if I were to tell you
I was not at Jones on third
in Studio City
eating some broccolini
and tuna
right before I was just unloading
in the toilet
I'd be someone else because that's what
happened to me if if you picture me an
hour and a half ago just not unloading
the sarlacc pit you know what I'm
talking about just absolutely well
that's the most disgusting way anyone's
ever put it but I mean man
it was so bad and then I was so bad that
I almost I thought I was going to start
throwing up yes dude
I just was nauseous man and I still am
but we fight through it and we do the
podcast don't we we fight through it we
do the podcast because I'm here for you
I'm here for you dude
and a lot of people but you know I've
been flirting with maybe ending the
podcast or whatever but not really but
you know what I mean but I think about
it right because it's like how long is
this podcast gonna go and we need to
make this Log Cabin already maybe we'll
just make the Log Cabin maybe every
podcast will be live from now on just in
the log cabin in The Tall Grass you know
cause I guarantee if I had a log cabin
and some Tall Grass people would move
and go there I know I have enough fans
you know but it's like I don't know
maybe I'll just keep it online keep it
virtual I'm not sure I thought that the
metaverse was going to be a thing for a
while and it's obviously not gonna be a
thing yet
uh but it could be it could be coming up
soon but I'm happy you're here with me
and uh and we're gonna keep doing this
podcast yes dude we're gonna keep doing
this podcast we can't stop it
um
they're gonna kill people in Uganda if
you're gay huh that's pretty crazy
you're gay you die and that's insane how
about that and America's up in arms
about that and then people are like well
we got enough problems don't be so up in
arms about another country when we know
that China and you know Russia are
pretty much on their way to just nuking
us but that's you know that's neither
here nor there when somebody's in Uganda
saying stuff like you know don't
identify I look if I think if you're gay
be gay be gayish be honestly be so gay
like be so gay to where you're just
dancing everywhere and just roller
skating
but in Uganda you can't even be like I'm
gay or you get killed and that is
absolutely unreal the the the it never
stops you never the thing things never
stop you know I'm talking about and I
know that really be basic but things
absolutely never stop like uh they they
used to kill gays and then it was
celebrated and then everyone you you
know thought back when the Grecian
people used to literally have sex with
other guys and think it was manly they
used to think it was like that like if
you didn't do it they're like you're gay
you don't you don't [__] guys okay
what are you a woman you know what I
mean and like and like then it became
out of fashion and then in fashion and
now Uganda is just like let's start this
over all over again
let's just start killing
and that's just too much I think
everyone should be totally totally
totally gay
and a matter of fact if you don't
[__] any guys as a guy in your whole
life
I think you personally I think you need
to be stoned and here's the deal I have
not done it yet but I'm only I'm uh you
know 42 I'm I'm a spring chicken
especially when it comes to gays because
dude you ever see a really old gay guy
that guy's floating I mean that's the
most gay guy and that's awesome and I
can't wait to be there because if I'm
not if I don't if I don't look dude if I
don't [__] one guy in my life
for real Stone like I Stone I think
I also think it's super gay of Uganda to
be like hey we're gonna kill you if
you're gay
because really that's means they're all
secretly gay if you have a problem with
something that has nothing to do with
you you've got some issues in with
inside of yourself like I used to say
this on my first special I said if you
met your friend and he was always like
dude [__] Butterfingers huh Butterfinger
Butterfingers are [__] [__] you'd
be like what happened between him and a
Butterfinger yeah
anus
pretty much if you've got a problem with
some it has nothing to do with you it
was in your anus
you know what I mean
so you got a problem with gays yeah guys
enjoy this
um anyway these are the kind of
hard-hitting facts that we talk about
here at the congratulations podcast but
I just think it's a big uh you know I
think it's a I think it's a big issue
when we talk about the hard-hitting
issues here
um I think uh you know
I want to be in a world
where it's just fine to be whatever you
want and except for Pedro Pascal
because
he's just in too much [__]
The Last of Us was it that's the you
know what's got to be crazy when you're
a star like that
and you just go like this oh this is the
year like Josh Brolin in 2021 or 2020 I
think it was or maybe even 19.
yeah it was 2019. where he's like oh
this is my year
I mean end game I'm in all sorts of [__]
you know what I mean he I like I'm a
model I wrote a book whatever he did
I have a cooking show you know
it's like uh oh dude this is it this is
your year
and when I have that year for me I'm
[__] so many dudes
[Music]
I can't wait to see Renovations honestly
Jeremy renner's coming out with
Renovations I'm going to the premiere he
invited me to it and it's on I can't
wait to do it there's a q a afterwards
I'm gonna meet him and I can't wait dude
that song by DMX ready to meet him
that's about me and Jeremy Renner
um
so yeah Uganda get it come on dude get
it together Uganda dude send me over
there guys guys guys guys guys guys guys
listen I think the problem lies within
yourself
um
I didn't even know by the way that
digital blackface was a thing I saw this
article on CNN CNN is I'm I fully
believe that it's just trolling at this
point CNN
it is so weird that look Fox News is say
what you want about
journalism used to be awesome right
journalism used to be great like in the
80s and [__] it used to be a blue-collar
job that people would have
and they would fight for the Common Man
none of the journalists had degrees and
then all of a sudden it became in
fashion why because the movies [__]
it up dude movies would come out and
there were like every third movie was
about a journalist just like hey I'm
trying to get to the bottom of this and
like a cool guy in like a tweed jacket
that was like you know uh sarcastic and
smarmy would take down the man and then
people wanted to do that because rich
people saw those movies and were like I
want to be a journalist so they went to
school for it and now they're in their
Ivory Terror towers and they don't know
[__] about what's going on with the
common man they're just like oh dude
I wanna you know
I want to talk about these issues that
don't matter
and so they're
now who's the New York Times for who's
CNN for
it's for [__] woke women who are 50
years old
that feel good because they feel guilty
they feel guilty so they feel good for
fighting for issues about things that
don't even really matter and they're
subscribing to the New York Times it's a
10 million subscriber base a year and
that's balling for them dude
and CNN they've got the what they so
they they say oh you might be here's the
thing too the article about digital
blackface
they don't know what the [__] what to
know about digital blackface what is
digital blackface and is it wrong when
white people use it
how about how uh
if you just put white in the uh
title people will click it
digital blackface here's the here's the
here's how the um
so digital black so here's what it is
digital blackface even though it's
nothing what it is is they say when you
use a gif or a meme or a picture online
and post it in reaction to something and
the picture is of a black person
overly emotional or sassy then you're
doing what's known as you're committing
digital blackface okay now we all know
that that's absolutely nothing because
sometimes you just pick a meme and you
use it now
they were saying if you use the meme
where the person's like ain't nobody got
time for that okay and you know what I
could you could argue that to me and I
could be like all right I get how if a
white person uses that they might think
it's funny because the black person is
being super black and sassy you know and
what they know to be black and sassy and
so they're perpetuating that you know
stereotypical so even though already
it's a fine line when you say that
because like dude I'm not thinking about
that [__] if I post a meme which I don't
do but like ah and I wouldn't post it
ain't nobody got time for that Meme or
whatever
but
here's the thing if you call white
people racist about
everything then you're just gonna lose
allies right
if if if
so let's go back to that so if you're
talking about that
meme okay I'll still think it's
ridiculous but fine but then they went
on to say the Tyra Banks one where she's
like yelling at someone I'm like I don't
even know that one and then I looked it
up and it's like it's just Tyra Banks
yelling they're not using it because
she's black they're using it because
she's Tyra Banks and then they said the
Jordan the Michael Jordan crying Meme
and I'm like okay you know what you lost
me dude nobody's posting this [__]
meme because Michael Jordan's black
they're doing it because it's Michael
Jordan and it's Michael Jordan crying
so guess what you lost Austin am I yes
and here's the deal if you are pushing
me
that far you're losing an ally and guess
what
it's just it's it's
digital blackface is now nothing
blackface is something you know every
now and then you get somebody where
they're like still how about the people
who are still doing it in Hall on the
Halloween
just fully knowing they're going to lose
money and jobs and they're just like
well yeah I mean but if we're gonna
dress up as
Denzel Washington and Pelican Brief I
mean how are people going to know we're
just gonna look like a white guy in a
suit
oh you know what I'll do it I'll do it
I'll pay yeah
I'll probably make my face Brown and not
black you know so
um but yeah man I don't really uh I
don't know so I think that CNN is fully
in the business of guys like me because
I was talking about this with my brother
and he was like dude who who would who
would agree with this like 70 17 of
people and I was like no way like four
and he was like no but that's not a good
business model but I think the business
model is just getting clicks because in
a sense when you click on something
you're funding
they're they're [__] you're funding
it in a sense
you're seeing the ads you're seeing the
you know and they pay for it and so they
pay for the the con the the the the [__]
the they pay for the ad space right and
I just uh I don't think CNN gives a [__]
where their clicks are coming from
anymore right
and I guess I was talking about this
with Kristen and they were like well
that's why Joe Rogan is so big now and I
guess you know he's because he's very
unbiased it seems you know he's just
kind of talking to people from both
sides of everything I don't know dude
whatever this is honestly let's talk
about pants because
it's too much it's too much but I was in
how could you believe anything the media
says period
crazy crazy
hey guys let's take a break I want to
talk to you about mood
um look whether you're new to cannabis
or an Old Pro there's no denying that
many of the products on the market seem
at best honestly iffy uh and when when
you want to relax iffy that is not how
you want to feel is it no it's not uh
mood puts an end to guessing games it's
100 federally legal Delta 8 and Delta 9
THC you could have shipped straight to
you no doctors no waiting just
Affordable Legal THC one and Ivan say
this is the way to shop for weed which
is uh you know they never lie you shop
by mood like Focus euphoric or creative
uh the product is incredible and priced
great they've been enjoying you for it
gummies uh they've been doing they told
me the fruity crispy treats and the THC
moon rocks and they did it easily dude
okay uh one of them's not the most tech
savvy and he did it and it got here fast
mood offers federally legal forms of THC
extracted from hemp plants all of their
products are regularly third-party
tested in drug enforcement agency
registered Labs sourced from small
family farms and grown organically
however you like to take THC mood has
you covered great for both beginner and
Veteran users yippee great tasting
gummies classic flower convenient
pre-rolls whatever yada yada so much
more ready for a good time without the
guesswork okay well order your THC
products from mood today and for 20 off
your first order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com and use promo code
congrats that's just for our listeners
that's
hellomood.com promo code congrats for 20
off your order and free gummies thanks
crazy
um
I feel like
uh I went to all first of all I did the
shows in where was I
Midland oh Midland dude hey Midland what
are you
hey Midland you got mid in the title hey
you're bad hey Midland you might as well
call yourself okaysville hey Midland you
might as well what was it between
Midland and ho hum City hey Midland you
got me hey try harder you know dude and
they were like well there's actually a
lot of money in Midland okay where I
just saw flat space I get that there's
oil there but it's like hey
I said a lot of money here oh yeah yeah
you got big people with a lot of money
here oh yeah where do they live Dallas
hey it's not Midland it's an hour away
dude Midland has an 81 million dollar
theater that I played okay uh did I sell
it out no why because Midland uh was it
a great show yes the people were awesome
there in Midland but even they were like
why are we here and the only reason that
night why people were there was because
me and
they made an 81 million dollar but which
by the way the theater is to the nines
we love it
and I'll go back but why was it there
I guess they're trying to make [__]
popping but dude it was literally in the
middle of nowhere I put on my Instagram
story people were like why are you here
and then I looked at my tour manager and
I was like why am I here
then went to Austin did two shows in
Austin do by the way
my tour manager was like Hey so we
booked Midland and then we got Austin
and I said great and he said here's the
thing and I said no
no come back to me before you have to
get to the point where you say so here's
the thing so rewind get rid of the point
in your life where the thing happened to
where you now need to come to me and say
so here's the thing
fix that and then come up to me and say
good to go
all right whenever I hear here's the
thing from my tour manager I go like
this
okay well here we go I'm bracing for
impact right
so he says
we're doing Midland and then we're doing
Austin
we gotta fly into Midland it's it's
connected
already connecting I don't want to do it
a connecting flight is basically it's
it's it's just
I so don't want to connect on a
connecting flight that
I would rather almost not do the gig
okay but I just say yes because I figure
whatever it's a city and I don't think
about the flights and then months down
the line where
figuring out what to do with the tour
and I'm like okay [__] I guess we got to
do a connective fight so we connect to
Midland so great so then he says but and
I go oh boy here we go and he says
Austin is an hour flight away but
there's no direct flight and that's when
the bee the blood red meter just it's at
the top of my eyes right I'm Bloods
Bloods just Rising
and I go and I'm like so then what the
[__] why don't we drive and he says it's
a six hour drive blood all the way up
above oh now it's at the top right and
I'm supposed because don't route those
two cities together it's so [__]
when two cities are close together and
you can play them together but you can't
take a direct flight and then it's like
well look into a private jet and it's
like oh but it's 20K and you're like
okay well cancel everything I'm going to
sleep
so he said so what do you want to do and
I said here's what I want to do I want
to drive through the night after my
Midland show because I'm not staying in
Midland for one extra [__] [__]
sucking second
so then I'm like
get this is very important get the what
do you call it Sprinter van where the
shit's lay down and we and we could
watch like some [__] dope
like Korean show where we could just
binge it all night to where we're
watching the the actors dub just like hi
where have you been
well I've just been out
I had dinner with Megan
and the subtitles are wrong brunch I had
brunch with Susan it says and you're
just like all right
you know we gotta pick one but um
subtitle or voiceover so uh he says okay
I'll do it I said but make sure that
they bring the right Sprinter van he
says I put it in the notes I said all
right great so we get done with the
Midland show now we're supposed to get
into the van and drive to Austin and my
tour manager comes up to me and he says
so here's the thing and I go no
rewind your life to where you have to
where you got to the point where you're
good we're gonna have to say so here's
the thing to me and fix it
I'm not a bad guy please work with me
here
and he says they showed up with the
wrong Sprinter van and I said what do
you mean and he says they don't have the
layback seats and I go well we got to
drive through the night and he says I
know so they're going to get a different
van and they're gonna be back in a half
an hour and I say great that's a little
bit annoying but it's way better and
they're gonna have a TV okay there was
no TV in the one that came with and they
said great I said great because the
mystery is it going at this point
because sometimes problems arise and I
understand that and it's not going to
make anything better by getting mad and
half an hour I could wait a half an hour
in this green room I'm just chilling
with Lou Gonzalez and then he love and
you know Sam my videographer and [__]
Enrique we're having a good time do it
30 minutes past and he comes back and he
says so here's the thing and I say no
it's the third time you say so here's
the thing
about this moment to me no
and he says
it'll be a few more hours if you want
that van or just take this van and I say
I've dealt
with all I can at this point
he says but the good thing is you're not
going to pay for it and I say oh well
that is a good thing because it's about
you know it's thousands of dollars to
get this van and take the ride so now I
don't have to pay for it okay
but let's get in the van and go to
Austin and it's going to take six hours
and it's 12 30 already at this point and
we got to stop at Whataburger you know
because it's gonna be there and I'm a
[__] pig and I'm gonna have to eat
two burgers because one Burger is a
snack and it doesn't come appetite dude
so we get in the thing dude the seats
not only do they go back I think they're
a little bit forward I'm like this
and they're so bad and we stop at
Whataburger now I don't have to pay for
the ride so I'm a little bit happy for
it but also I'd rather just pay the [__]
and have to lay down shits and watch a
Korean drama
no TV no no sitting no you know
my videographer's on the floor we're
gonna crash he's just gonna lose all of
his body parts so we get to the uh
Whataburger and they're like have you
ever had Whataburger and I said yeah but
I don't remember and they say dude top
five Lulu Gonzalez says it's in my top
five burgers and I say really I don't
remember that and she says it is because
in-n-out's trash and I go like this
you're lost to me in and out to me the
best burger staying power out the Wazoo
and then people are like yeah but the
fries suck dude if you're going to a
burger place because of the fries your
priorities are all mismatched yes yes I
[__] think of the good things
so I'm just like all right let's get a
Whataburger what do we get now my tummy
has been on fire and gurgling and making
my anus open up like a sarlacc pit for
about two weeks now so this burger
situation I gotta be real careful but
then I noticed they've got a jalapeno
burger so I go like this without
thinking one please but then I also
don't want to get the thing that isn't
the regular thing at Whataburger because
I want the regular thing at Whataburger
so I know where to rank it in my Burgers
of course yes I think about the right
thing so I also get a double
cheeseburger because that's regular my
baby so I say what jalapeno burger
you know sayonara to this tummy and then
also a regular one because I just want
to try both now they showed up I ain't
[__] both of them all of them yes did
I leave one by left over on either of
them no
dude
so I ate the two Whataburgers and
honestly dude I gotta tell you
they're all they're good and that's it
and I said the fact that this is in the
top five is absolutely bonkers
I could name so many burgers better than
Whataburgers so the people from Texas
that love Whataburgers and the people
from the South are like Whataburger is
the [__] I know what you're doing dude I
absolutely know what you're doing
you're just trying to be in the game you
try to have an interesting opinion
because Whataburger you want it to be
the Dark Horse but let me tell you
something dude it's not the Dark Horse
it's fine and then I ate a dude Danny
love agreed with me he was like this is
kind of okay it's mid it was mid and I
don't even say that and I've been to
Midland
and uh so we leave we go back to to
Austin we get there at 6 30 a.m now we
have been up because here's the thing
too because we went to we were gonna fly
in the day before on Midland look at
that [__] look at that dude my tricep
isn't even it's not even Flappy I mean
it's a little flat but if that's muscle
but dude so we we were gonna fly in the
middle of the day before because I do
that I like to get my rest right I used
to go the day of but now I'm like 42 and
I'm like dude I don't want to be tired
so I used to fly the day I used to fly
the day out but now I fly the day before
to get my rest but then what I did was
instead of that
because the flight was going to be
delayed and we weren't going to make and
we were going to maybe not make our
connection
I was like [__] it let's just go
tomorrow morning so we flew the day of
to Midland so we got we had to leave we
didn't get picked up at 4am so we got
about 3 30 right so which means we
didn't you know I go to bed you know I'm
a [__] car I go to bed at one so I
got we all had two hours of sleep meet
David Sullivan and Sam the videographer
who my son calls him Sam the guy because
we have Sam the dog and now he calls him
Sam the dog and he was call him Sam the
guy the whole time I was like I'm gonna
die guy and he says because we have Sam
the dog and I was like oh my heart
melted so anyway we got
other plane had no sleep got on the van
uh the Sprinter no sleep on the Sprinter
I got maybe an hour or two David
Sullivan sat up like this the whole time
I can't sleep man because I'm sharing
the scene with Enrique Ting and so we
get to San Antonio at night [__] yeah
this is so interesting and we get there
at 7 00 a.m and David Sullivan dude I
wake up at 1pm and I see texts from
David Sullivan at the golf course he was
there at [__] nine dude he was there
at 9am with a bright orange shitty golf
shirt and shorts that were too baggy
dude I and I'm like here I am like why
do you even have that like did you pack
that shirt bro did you know you're gonna
be doing this [__]
he had a total of two hours of sleep for
two whole days three days
actually two nights
so I'm like bro
you're gonna die
there comes a moment where you're not
you don't even just you don't even sleep
you just like you're so tired that you
don't fall asleep you pass away
right that's gonna be David David's
gonna be like this
like he's gonna be man I'm tired just
and so
so he's so tired and then
you know I'm [__] at Whataburger and
he's [__] [__] at Whataburger and
he won't go to sleep and so we did the
show and then he helped [__] run the
cameras for the show and then afterwards
dude it was 3 A.M and we were eating
Velvet Taco which is banging dude now I
know what I look at all there's all the
[__] I eat literally this is what the
[__] tummy is so
April when I have a month off dude I'm
gonna be eating salads and [__]
walking uphill with lunges dude it's
gonna be insane man I'm gonna look so
good come [__] me in Cincinnati when
I'm in Cincinnati come May in Cincinnati
when I come to Cincinnati dude I'm gonna
look so good Jason Momoa is going to be
like oh [__]
I've decided something I'm going to do
movies again I'm going to do movies
again and I'm going to do TV again and
there's nothing anybody can do about it
I'm gonna [__] be on the [__] and I'm
going to be acting so good and you're
gonna be blown away uh Blown Away dude
blown away I'm gonna play a guy who
stutters I'm gonna play a Korean guy no
makeup I'm gonna be playing I'm gonna
you think I'm not gonna play a twink I'm
gonna play a twink dude and I'm gonna
guess what I'm gonna do no research and
I'm just gonna come in blow the doors
off not get nominated for [__] because
of we know the woke environment but
you're gonna know secretly that your boy
needs to be nominated and I'm being dead
dude I'm gonna play a woman a woman not
a trans woman a woman
I know trans women are women
but a woman from just like you know what
I'm talking about like Ben Shapiro would
be like that's a one that's a woman like
that that kind of woman
that's what I'm gonna play dude
trans women are women or whatever you
know I don't know dude I don't care I
don't know
like some people are like yeah but don't
stay silent or it's perpetuating that
nah dude guess what zip that's it
unzip because I got to do the podcast
but zip do it
like I'm not I don't I don't care about
all the issues yeah I don't give a [__]
oh but that's your privilege okay
how about that dude and you know what
people are doing right now they're
listening to me they're going like this
[__] yeah you're right dude I'm gonna I
feel that way but you can't say it
because you got a regular job but I can
because I'm on patreon and I can because
I do stand up and dude you know what man
it's great I can't wait to do this
special and have it come out man this
[__] is [__] bonkers
what if I was the kind of comedian that
was like dude we're gonna change the
game with this special
hey guys now that my shit's out the
games change dude we had to change
they're trying to silence us
dude they can't
I love that [__] like like and that's so
funny when people just have like a
[__] inflated self-importance dude
whatever I'm [__] so important
I'm a run for [__] governor
previously on the governor starring
Chris D'Elia that's gonna be me on ABC
dude when I come back and just [__]
acting as a woman Governor not somebody
who's trans
Ben Shapiro is going to be like oh it's
crystalia I thought it was a woman he's
really good
[Music]
previously on the governor
hey guys you really need to pass that
bill
[Music]
previously on the governor I love you
but it's different because God there's
so many judges
[Music]
previously on the governor
no I know but God move away move
lobbyists I'm trying to get to my
meeting
wow no nothing about
[Laughter]
oh dude nobody grows up and says one day
I'm gonna be a lobbyist
it's never happened
it's happened more where people say when
I grow up I'm going to be a crack [__]
[Music]
previously on crack [__] starring
crystalia I really no you have to you
you have to use one I'm scared of St
previously on crack [__] starring
crystalia it's 25 dollars
[Music]
previously on crack horse during
crystalia I'll do it for 12. okay
um
previously on crack [__] starring
crystalia freeze oh no not again
at least I'm not a lobbyist
um
yeah do it
somebody wrote me and they were like I
can't believe you did a post about
digital blackface uh I really [__] with
you for a while now but you know you
said some things that really irked me
about my community I I don't even know
if it was a black person I suppose it
wasn't they were like
um
you know
you're saying things that really irk me
how could you do this when my community
is in shambles and I'm just like
I just read it and I go like this huh
but also
everything's in shambles you know
I don't know
oh God no idea
um I actually uh
I'm good dude
I want to get you added man I am mean I
am fighting nausea the whole time here
so that's cool I uh
I'm gonna try and not dude you know what
I I Pat me myself on the backboard dude
I did [__] shows this week and I had
two in one day I didn't lose my voice
yeah so that means I think my voice will
be okay for shooting my special
um on Saturday in Minneapolis
uh What's it gonna say about the [__]
uh sit with me but sit with me guys sit
with me for a second because I can't I
can't remember what the hell I was gonna
say and it was gonna be absolutely great
it was gonna blow the dollar so I was
gonna change the podcast game
um too many people have a podcast huh I
saw podcast the other day and guys were
just you know what they were doing
they're just talking
and it's like dude
don't have that
I feel like
I have to go to the bathroom
I'll be right back uh I'm back man I'm
just relaxing bro I'm just relaxing I
had to go potty I can't help it
I I I I'm it's like
oh oh oh this this clip dude is so funny
to me this guy is the most the [__] guy
of all time
okay where are you working bro you got
plenty of cash plenty
put you on my black I got somebody for
y'all you know what I'm saying bro this
hair is a hat you know with a brimp yeah
what's your type
you like black white I like white girls
more better okay
so could not I like white girls more
better
words
in other words POG pod that's what I
like yeah are you being a politician
about it in other words Park
fat ass white girls
we
gonna hold you up [__] to do not someone
dude they're so trolling him does he
know this guy is so a guy I would be
friends with in high school in New
Jersey I can't even believe it dude I
would denying you my name right here
Joshua Henderson
all right bro all right bro we're gonna
holler forget that taking it our name be
the last thing you'll ever hear a little
bit of the word bro all right bro are
you taking it what's his mouth doing
dude in the middle of the guy's dog he's
just like
good luck
I got it gotta go back to that part dude
that's my favorite part
I mean that is so funny to me hold on
come on
okay here we go oh the snow rabbit here
we go yeah other [__] so what's your
name again bro before we go bro cause we
gotta go man hang on we ain't gonna hold
you up I ain't gonna lie to you what's
your name here my name Joshua Henderson
all right bro oh since you're swallowing
so much forget that
may my name be the last time
singing voice bro all right bro all
right you take it easy now bro dude hey
good luck don't forget about it
Barack Obama a little bit
about it ever
um
dude that guy
is so dope God I would be that guy's
friend so hard you can tell he's got the
worst breath of all time um I mean
there's no question that that boy or man
whatever he is has the worst breath of
all time and it's okay but Joshua
Henderson is [__]
oh oh his profile he is so dope I mean
the [__] picture in the thing
what is it a regular video of his like
okay he's just dancing all right
well this guy's getting oh here we go
well it's not just pogs I like King
I like huge chungas too
as a member okay huge Changas um
you know what is this guy saying here
what's up y'all oh I wanted to ask y'all
something oh y'all think I'm
light-skinned or not
I mean wow
Izzy light-skinned
um
fat ass white girls
I love that guy
who's Saucy or him or the pope is that
is that that's not a real jacket that he
wore right that's the AI [__] dude AI
looks so real it's I can't like the pope
image he looks so flossing dude why
didn't he do that
AI Pope dude
you can't tell it's not
it's so this is AI he didn't really wear
this jacket
oh dude
how do they do this how do I do that I
want to make AI stuff
I can do it
really
you could always tell because of the
hands though right
let's see the pope is absolutely
oh even the hand they got their hands
okay with this one no not really
um
yeah the pope is uh
he should dress like that dude if the
pope really dressed like that in the AI
[__] then more people would fall would
be religious and it would and it would
be like people would like it like cool
[__] would be religious
they need a good PR too
man I've been watching this chat this
GPT or no sorry the the tick tock thing
about the uh should it be banned or not
dude it is so hilarious how the
government is like
oh and what about scrolling you're just
gonna let scrolling happen
and the guy's like excuse me can I know
okay I'm not done they're not even
letting them talk the guy just is so
obviously a good guy you can just tell I
don't give a [__] should Tick Tock be
banned no here's the thing we got way
worse [__]
in the world happening that's that we
need to worry about then [__] tick
tock
I don't give a [__] have all my
information I didn't [__] I don't
care dude you know
this guy's so the the tick tock [__]
dude about how they
where's the
The Tick Tock oh wait what
The Tick Tock [__] where the there's all
that's ever come up why Tick Tock should
just push this
so here we go it's right here oh it was
just right there
for me
here we go
are neither new nor unique to tick-tock
for example I was disturbed by reports
that Tick Tock content modeling no she's
actually being good about it again we do
not collect body face or voice data to
identify our users
they're looking at the eyes how do you
determine what age they are then
um we rely on age skating SLK Assurance
gating which is when you ask the user
what HDR we have also developed some
tools where we look at the public
profile to go through the videos that
they post to see whether that's creepy
tell me
well that's creepy tell me more about
that
I mean so creepy has his dick in his
hand well that's creepy tell me more
about that hold on a second all right
I'm ready
he's public so if you oh slam them
slander to Infinity dude slam them to
Infinity right there
you can pause the video that you choose
that video to go public that's how you
get people to see your video we look at
those to see if you it matches up the
age that you talked about slammed into
Infinity I've never seen a harder slam
than that well he's public
well that's creepy tell me more about
that
well it's public
[Music]
industry because
being so respectful it's a really big
problem
we're talking about tick tock
children have died because of this do
you have any idea can you tell watch
this part uh Congressman again is
heartbreaking can you tell me how many
children in America have died because of
challenges like this the majority of
people who use help platform use it for
positive experiences that's not what I
ask you can I ask you tell me the number
of children of U.S children who have
died because of these challenges dude
just be like this two I don't know why
does it why don't they just do that
because the problem is he's being too
much of a respectful adult dude they're
really coming for that ass
I don't know how many people
how many people because say something
how many people die because of whatever
blank and the Congress you know they're
back on their heels again
number dangerous changes look it up
louder than our platform if we find them
we will remove them we take this route
obviously you found one today and you
removed it we had to bring it to your
attention I know I'm out of time thank
you for being here welcome again to the
most bipartisan Committee in Congress
welcome remember I'm out of time and
welcome to the time welcome to my back
so lucky days ago well you know it's all
good but I got you know he didn't tell
me about the how many people died
um
he should have been like how many people
how many people had the US government
killed
oh my God could you imagine
they would have literally just shot him
right there
well I didn't like that answer man I
still wanted to hear about you know the
creepy thing I got my [__] out
well that's creepy tell me more about
that that's a great sound why is that
not a sound I think well that's creepy
why don't you tell me more about that
people like creepy stuff you know why is
that why is that a turn on why don't
people like why do people like uh secret
stuff why dude
you know
don't tell anyone
well that's creepy tell me more about
that
well it's public just slam them to a
[__]
the guy's spinning out another in a
different world
what's with that dude if I see going to
the power what is Gwyneth Paltrow on
trial for being too white I don't
understand
every time I look at it it's like well I
was skiing and he bumped into me
and then and then she's like it's so
white woman to be like and it was sexual
assault like what what was happening
what was happening
Gwyneth Paltrow what what did you do
what somebody's like I can't taste
anymore this is the whitest [__]
it's so white I was skiing
he bumped into me I'm gonna say it's
sexual assault and now he can't taste
anymore those are the things that I
know about the case
it's too white they say Oscar's too
white Gwyneth Paltrow
case too white
and she's got the nerve to dress like
Jeffrey Dahmer with the sunglasses or
whatever everything is so
Gwyneth
Paltrow
here we go
ski video there's a ski video
oh did something happen oh she crashed
into someone and then a guy suing her
sanderson's original complete fought
against Patrick that Patrol allegedly
skied out of control and hit the back of
Terry Sanderson
another skier who was downhill knocking
him
it was down on knocking him down hard
knocking him out and causing a brain
injury for broken ribs another
I mean Jesus you know
who's at fault here in other words don't
escape the prisoners
okay this is I mean the whitest [__] of
all time we will try to get through you
quickly we're at the end of the day oh
it's live right now no way dude no way
who would watch this dude I wouldn't
even watch a Johnny Depp thing [__]
Kristen was glued to that [__]
[__] so white
oh come on turn on please it's so hot in
here hi Anne um
69 got hospitalized uh from getting
jumped that here's the thing about 69
getting uh jumped why did it happen so
late
it happened so late
I love too that like he denied
uh government protection and it didn't
happen until I have it in the bathroom
of a 24 Hour Fitness why the [__] is six
nine working out
like just be gross you know what I mean
what does six nine doing at the gym
imagine I'm on the treadmill with like
big jeans and just his hair flopping all
over just sweating so gross
stop like don't what bro rappers working
out is [__] hilarious
aren't they too cool
I thought Gangsters Don't Dance we
Boogie how you gonna work out you live
weights though maybe but six nine went
to the bathroom of the uh the 24 Hour
Fitness got jumped by some you know I
don't know probably Mexicans and [__]
smashed them up and you have to be
hospitalized because snitches get
stitches why did it take so long we
don't know but he denied government uh
protection
also I would have loved dude if I was
six nine I would have straight up gone
into hiding like with government like uh
Protection Program I would have gone to
Alaska hid still been me I would like
cut my hair a little bit and then still
kept rapping and then become another
name I would have become another I was
still I would have made it again and I
would just call myself 70.
Takashi 7-0
like [__] it take all the stuff and they
like
and then I just think it's amazing that
it took this long
how amazing would have been if just
white guys just beat the [__] out of
them snitches get stitches you know
that's it for the episode on YouTube if
you want to get the raw the uncut the
unedited episode go on over to uh
patreon patreon.com crystallia and have
added six dollars and you get all of the
back loaded episode backlogged episodes
of uh of uh what do you call it uh
there's like 25 of them at this point so
go get it just six bucks to get all that
content thanks very much
[Music]
thank you